>> Laura: CONGRESS HAS A MARCH L
>> Laura: CONGRESS HAS A MARCH N
>> Laura: CONGRESS HAS A MARCH
>> Laura: CONGRESS HAS A MARCH O
>> Laura: CONGRESS HAS A MARCH H
>> Laura: CONGRESS HAS A MARCH M
>> Laura: CONGRESS HAS A MARCH E
>> Laura: CONGRESS HAS A MARCH R
>> Laura: CONGRESS HAS A MARCH O
>> Laura: CONGRESS HAS A MARCH T
AN IMMIGRATION PLAN BEFORE DACA
PROTECTIONS EXPIRED FOR ABOUT
800,000 OF THE SO-CALLED
DREAMERS.
WEEK OF AMNESTY FOR NEARLY
2 MILLION ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IN
EXCHANGE FOR BORDER SECURITY AND
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION CUTS.
REPUBLICAN SENATOR DAVID PERDUE
IS ONE OF THE MEN BEHIND IT.
HE JOINS US NOW WITH MORE.
SENATOR, ALWAYS GREAT TO SEE
YOU.
I RAN INTO YOU AND A NEW EVENT
ON SATURDAY AND I SAID YOU
BETTER COME ON THE SHOW, AND
HERE YOU ARE, SO THANK YOU.
THAT KIND OF IN SOME WAYS
MIRRORS WHAT WAS GOING ON IN THE
HILL WITH GOODLATTE AND MIKE
McCALL.
IT WAS FOCUSED ON THE 800,000
DACA PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT KIDS,
THEY ARE ADULTS NOW FOR THE MOST
PART.
THREE OR AFFORDED LATER SUDDENLY
IT'S AT 1.8 MILLION.
BECAUSE YOU NEEDED TO PICK UP A
FEW PEOPLE?
>> IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU.
A YEAR AGO YOU HAD TOM COTTON
AND MYSELF ON HERE AND WE
WE WARNED ABOUT THE DIVERSITY
LOTTERY AND WE SAID WE NEEDED AN
END TO CHAIN MIGRATION.
WHAT WE'VE DONE THERE, THE
PRESIDENT HAS LAID OUT, I
OUT IF PEOPLE ARE REALLY SERIOUS
ABOUT SOLVING THIS IMMIGRATION
PROBLEM ON BOTH SIDES.
I THINK WE HAVE THE FRAMEWORK TO
ACTUALLY GET IT DONE.
>> Laura: MY LISTENERS ARE
LIVID.
I DON'T MESS ON THEIR SHOW FOR
THE LAST THREE OR FOUR DAYS AND
WHEN DID HE CAMPAIGN ON THIS?
MY POINT IS THAT IF YOU WANT
CUTS IN LEGAL IMMIGRATION, WHICH
IS THE BIG NUMBER, 1 MILLION
GREEN CARDS EVERY YEAR, MOST OF
THOSE ARE BASED NOT ON MERIT BUT
ON EXTENDED FAMILY TIES, AUNTS,
UNCLES, COUSINS TWICE REMOVED.
FEELINGS AND SENSIBILITIES WHO
WHAT YOU SAY TO THOSE AMERICANS,
AMERICANS WERE UPSET AND THE
PEOPLE WAITING IN LINE?
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS REALLY LAID
OUT HE WANTS AN END TO DACA.
WHAT THAT MEANS IS HE WANTS TO
PROVIDE -- THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
GET IN FRONT OF ANYBODY, BUT
WHAT HE IS ALSO DONE IS GIVEN
THE CONSERVATIVES OF HIS PARTY
WHAT HE PROMISED HE WOULD DO, A
SAFE AND SECURE BORDER WITH THE
WALL.
HE WANTS TO END CHAIN MIGRATION,
THE MOST INSIDIOUS PART OF THIS.
IT'S WHAT'S CAUSED US TO BE
HERE.
AND WE KNOW WE HAVE A SECURITY
ISSUE WITH THE DIVERSITY LOTTERY
KRISTEN GILLIBRAND, SHE'S
ALREADY KICKING OFF HER CAMPAIGN
PRACTICALLY, HER VIEWS ON CHAIN
MIGRATION.
>> I THINK A LOT OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S RHETORIC IS
RACIST, AND LET'S BE VERY CLEAR,
WHEN SOMEONE USES THE PHRASE
"CHAIN MIGRATION," IT IS
DEMONIZE FAMILIES AND MAKE IT A
RACIST SLUR.
>> IT'S VERY INTERESTING.
THEY WERE OUT OF TOUCH WHEN THEY
TRIED TO SHUT THE GOVERNMENT
DOWN.
THE SHIMMER SHUTDOWN.
THE IDEA, THE TERM CHAIN
MIGRATION WAS TERMED BY
LYNDON B. JOHNSON, I THINK HE
WAS A DEMOCRAT.
BILL CLINTON ALSO CALLED FOR AN
END WHEN HE AND BARBARA JORDAN
WANTED TO GO TO A MERIT BASED
SYSTEM LIKE CANADA AND
AUSTRALIA.
THIS IS NOTHING MORE THAN
DEMOCRATS REVEALING HOW FAR OUT
OF TOUCH THEY ARE.
TWO-THIRDS WANTS TO ENTRY
MIGRATION AND THE LOTTERY FIX
THE DACA PROBLEM AND BUILD THAT
WALL.
>> Laura: SHE KEPT SAYING
>> TOTALLY.
>> Laura: SOME OF THE POLLS
AMERICA THE ONE MIGRATION.
68% OPPOSE THE VISA LOTTERY.
81% WANT LEGAL IMMIGRATION
REDUCED.
THAT'S ALWAYS THE CASE WHETHER
IT'S THE GALLUP POLL OR THE
INADEQUATE.
STEVE KING WAS ON MY SHOW ON
FRIDAY, HE SAID THIS.
>> THE NUMBERS ARE JUST
STUNNING.
IT TO SEE THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAS PROPOSED 1.8 MILLION AMNESTY
FOR ILLEGALS.
I THINK THIS WILL DEMORALIZE SO
PLACE WHERE WE NEED TO BE WITH
THIS?
>> THE ANSWER IS VERY SIMPLE.
KEEP OUR EYES FOCUSED ON THE
GOT US FOCUSED HERE IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
CHAIN MIGRATION ON THE LOTTERY.
>> Laura: NO MORE AMNESTY
AFTER THIS?
THIS WILL BE THE LAST?
>> THIS IS THE IDEA, TO END THE
PROBLEM IN THE FIRST PLACE.
7 MILLION OR MORE.
>> Laura: YOU THINK YOU WILL
GET ENOUGH DEMOCRATS TO SUPPORT
THIS?
>> WE WILL FIND OUT IF THEY ARE